[Musique]
les a
tout s'est effacé ma mémoire qu'est ce
qui s'est passé après
le matin très tôt j'ai reçu un appel de
l'hôpital tu avais été transporté tu
étais blessé je suis venu te voir je
suis passé dans la rue du restaurant il
y avait des fleurs et dessins d'enfants
découle un couloir dans lequel les
jeunes ont défilé
ce que vous pouvez vous asseoir ailleurs
selon mes parents étaient assis
vous sauvez moi
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites ici vous vous
êtes précipité dans les toilettes au
premier coup de feu et vous n'avez pas
ouvert j'ai pas fait ça
pareco souvenait de tout ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi voulez-vous s'ouvrir
je m'en vais retourner au musée où ils
ont été
la dernière chose qu'ils ont
l'impression de leur dire au revoir
[Musique]
faut qu'on fasse ce qu'il aurait dû
faire ce soir là
j'ai fait ça c'est dur et j'aurais
préféré y est on se prépare à tenter
bien sûr quelques sourires ça puisse
gêner
[Musique]
avant je me demandais j'avais si j'étais
heureuse
non mais